hi 80 and all you hearties it's me Aaron
Creek oh here in my little kitchen in my
home in LA on lockdown this is such an
unusual weird scary time for all of us
and I'm sending you all so much love and
support wherever you are and a big thank
you to all of the essential workers from
healthcare to grocery stores they call
you essential workers for a reason you
are essential to all of us so thank you
from the bottom of my heart one of the
questions I get asked the most
aside from is it uncomfortable wearing a
corset yes it is is is Erin as bad a
chef as Elizabeth if it's true what they
say that the way to a man's heart is
through his stomach you could be accused
of attempted murder I don't think I'm as
bad as Elizabeth she may not be known
for her culinary skills but I can hold
my own and so tonight we're gonna be
making brownies smells chocolatey I
found this recipe by half-baked harvest
a blogger I follow Emily Schumann made
it recently and they looked so good that
I thought I gotta try these myself so
we're gonna start at the very beginning
which is washing our hands I'm going to
wash mine for the 500th time today first
we're going to preheat the oven to 350
degrees and while that's working what I
have here is not a brownie pan I don't
have one in my kitchen so I'm going with
this 9-inch nonstick
hi listen I don't need to know what
everything is called as long as it
tastes good so I'm going to put it on
top of a piece of parchment paper and
draw around the base of my pan to make a
circle and I'm going to take my scissors
cut out okay then I have my little
parchment circle and I'm going to place
it inside the pan so satisfying that's
actually a pretty good fit in the
microwave you are going to melt together
most of your two cups of chocolate and
your butter this is about a cup and a
half and now I'm going to add the butter
oh that's probably not the best way of
doing this isn't it butter buttered in
the bowl with the chocolate now we're
gonna microwave this let's start with 30
seconds it happens
this looks it's like a swamp of butter
and chocolate but it's gonna look better
let's see you might be wondering why
there's a teddy bear on top of the
refrigerator
it's my baking partner say hi Randy
so now I'm supposed to mix in the sugar
vanilla and instant coffee I need more
space I'm gonna transfer this to a
bigger bowl okay adding the sugar this
is 1 and 1/2 cups granulated sugar a
tablespoon of good vanilla I'm skipping
the coffee I know
coffee is really supposed to bring out
all of the flavors in chocolate but I
don't drink coffee and I don't miss it
that much they're killing me dog next I
have to whisk together 4x oh look at
that
Kevin would be very proud of me it's
good stuff 4 eggs
boom wash my hands again because it's
gross eggs now I'm just going to whisk
these together till they're right and
walk to you and bubbly on top okay now I
have to add eggs into the chocolate
mixture so it's probably a good idea to
make sure your chocolate mixture isn't
too hot when you add in the eggs
nobody wants scrambled eggs and their
brownies
scrambled eggs I should probably use
some kind of sifter for this so I
grabbed this guy half a cup of
unsweetened cocoa powder one shoe a
teaspoon of baking powder half a cup of
all-purpose flour and this is kind of
hard to come by these days this little
trick I learned in home AK you take the
back of a knife and scrape it over the
top of it that's how you know you have
the exact amount now I'm gonna go like
this
to sift it on into our chocolate mixture
make sure there aren't any lumps my eyes
are closed I feel like we're close okay
so everything is incorporated ideally
you're using a 9 by 13 brownie pan I
have a 9 inch pie pan so we're gonna
just bake this a little bit longer and
it's gonna make a thicker brownie whoa
all right we've got our brownie batter
in the pan
smells delicious and it looks like that
the oven is preheated we're gonna stick
this in for 30 to 35 minutes and see
what happens
good luck to us now we wait she's
probably asleep I'm gonna go with that
she wouldn't just be screening my calls
Elizabeth rosemary beautiful see if it's
done came out clean that's a good sign
we're just gonna let this cool for a
while and then cut into it okay guys
real talk um I was going to attempt to
remove the brownie situation from the
pan off camera just in case it went
poorly and I started by taking a butter
knife and just kind of going just going
around the edge to kind of loosen the
brownie high from the pan but then I
don't know I still believe this is
salvageable so I'm going to just I'm
just gonna attempt to flip it because it
feels like it's been loosened the top
won't be the top anymore the top will
now be the bottom but didn't have to be
rules where's me like one two three
oh so I decided to get another plate
because the bottom isn't so pretty so
we're gonna try to make the bottom the
bottom again instead of the top okay
okay I feel like you shouldn't judge me
on this what matters most is how it
tastes so I'm just gonna it's so gooey
opportunity to prove myself no that's
not I don't think it's done okay here's
the deal if you're going to use a nine
inch pie pan and make your brownies this
thick you're gonna need more than 32
[Music]
well I think the moral of the story is
brownie down let's just let's just taste
a corner just took part that looks done
so delicious oh um thanks for joining me
everyone mistakes are how you learn by
[Music]